it is that season again which means it's
time to Spook it up here on the channel
and what better way to do that than to
dive back into the world of Jin and
Spirits in the islamicate and Middle
Eastern World we've all watched the
Hollywood horror movies that in
different ways depict cases of demonic
possession from the classic The Exorcist
to the more recent Conjuring movies it's
a topic that keeps fascinating and
unsettling people around the world but
these stories are often very Christian
Centric in their nature the demonology
that is presented is almost exclusively
based on Christian Theology and the
solution often involves at least in some
way things like crucifixes and holy
water now there have been some
diversifying developments such as the
2019 movie The vigil which depicts an
encounter with a Jewish possessing
Spirit called the tiic but what about
the Islamic world of Jinn to many people
they're not knowledge of Jin is limited
to uh Genies in movies like Aladdin and
to say the least this is not necessarily
capture the nature and and
characteristics of the actual Jin from
the Islamic world and what about
possession can Jin actually possess
human beings and if so are there some
interesting or known examples of this
throughout history today we're going to
explore the fascinating and really
interesting world of Jin possession in
the Islamic and Middle Eastern
[Music]
world the Jinn are a vast and
fascinating group of beings I've already
covered Jin in a general sense a few
years ago which you can check out if for
if you want a deeper overview but in
shorter terms Jin are a group of beings
in Middle Eastern and Islamic lore that
can take on many different forms and
shapes they appear in the Quran and so
have been established as an important
component of the Islamic religion even
though they may have been interpreted in
different ways in the Quran it says
quote and he created Jin from smokeless
fire thus Jin are a type of being that
exists in the world created from
smokless fire and that is distinct from
humans who were created from clay and
Angels created from light Jin are
conceived as creatures mostly invisible
to human senses but they can sometimes
become perceivable and even interact
with us in different ways often most
people will talk about JY as exclusively
evil creatures perhaps equivalent to
Demons in Christianity but this is
actually not accurate instead Jin are
actually neutral beings more similar to
how actual dionis in ancient Greece
actually functioned that they could be
both evil and good they're not not not
necessarily one or the other Jin have
societies of their own they have
families uh they even have religion so
there are Muslim Jin there are Christian
Jin Jewish Jin Etc and as I said they
can be both friendly or dangerous both
good and evil with that said even in the
Islamic world the Jin are mostly
associated as being evil creatures for
the most part but officially this is the
case Jin can be both good and evil in
fact Jin is sometimes seen more as a
kind of umbrella term for all kinds of
different beings with characteristics of
their own and Under The Wider term of
Jin we have beings that are more
exclusively and decidedly evil or
dangerous such as the the mar the andan
or indeed in Islamic theology it is
considered that El or Satan is in fact a
Jin looking at the folklore of many
regions and cultures around the world we
can find many different examples of
supernatural beings or creatures that
became subsumed Under The Wider category
of Jin it is also common to say that the
polytheist god of other religions in
other words false gods according to
Islam are in fact gin that humans have
mistakenly interpreted to be Gods so as
you can see the world of the Jin is a
very large and complex one but our top
IC of interest and focus today is more
narrow and specific namely the question
about Jin possession Jin can be found
basically everywhere but are
particularly associated with dark places
with old ruins and cemeteries humans can
encounter them in different ways but can
they actually become
possessed well we have a clue for this
in the Arabic word for a Madman or crazy
person majnun such as the famous love
story of Lea and majnon majnun Moon
literally means something like possessed
by a Jin and you can tell just by
looking at the name and seeing that it
has the same three-letter root in Arabic
in fact the question of gin possession
has been a contested issue among Islamic
scholars not everyone agrees that it is
a real thing as an example of a
non-septic the famous 14th Century
theologian and hanbali jurist ibben
Tamia often seen as a founding figure of
salafism wrote that quote the existence
of the Jin is an established fact
according to the book the Sunnah and the
agreement of the early Scholars likewise
the penetration of the Jin into the
human body is also an established fact
according to the consensus of leading
Sunni Scholars the Jin enters one seized
by fits and causes him to speak
incomprehensible words unknown to
himself if one seized by fits is struck
with a blow enough to kill a camel he
does not feel it on the other hand there
are other major historical Islamic
scholars that have denied its reality
such as
fzi the literalist ibam and maybe even
Al
gazali IB haam calls it Superstition and
says that quote such things are not
possible in other words people don't
fall for it except to the weak minds of
the elderly that he the devil can speak
using someone's tongue is sinity and
clear Insanity we seek protection in God
from deception and affirming
superstitions but regardless we can be
sure that it is and has been a very
common opinion that gin possessions do
indeed happen and there exists and have
existed various techniques and
traditions related to how to get rid of
such Spirits through different kinds of
exorcism there are different words for
Jin possession in Arabic one of which is
s and a person possessed thus becomes a
Mas another common term is mus meaning
to touch or feel just like in a lot of
ancient traditions of spirit possession
such as m hamia the possession of Jin is
often connected with disease especially
mental
afflictions if someone shows signs of a
mental disorder this could be a sign of
Jin possession we saw from IB Tamia's
quote that symptoms could include
speaking incomprehensible words and of
being seized by fits all of which could
be symptoms of some sort of mental
disorder from the earliest recorded
periods we find the idea that Jin can
somehow affect human beings in different
ways
The pre-islamic Poets were often thought
to get their inspiration from such
Spirits which allowed them to compose
such beautiful verses and similar ideas
still exist in certain parts of the
Islamic world today so what are some
examples of this in Morocco there is a
famous Jin called Aisha
kandisha usually Jinn will be referred
to and understood collectively or as a
general whole but there are examples
such as here of specific individual Jin
or with names and characteristics of
their own Aisha kandisha is a
frightening creature that will often
take on the form of a human woman and
seduce unsuspecting men either killing
and eating them or sometimes even
possessing them stories about men
possessed by Lady Aisha are reported to
lose interest completely in human women
and suffer various kinds of physical and
mental ailments another example comes
from Central Asian and Kurdish lore
where there is a type of Jin called the
Al which targets women and pregnant
women in particular the AL can steal
babies and even the fetus from pregnant
women and eat them which of course
reminds us of certain creatures from
Mesopotamian lore such as the lilu and
the demon lashu the AL is also said to
be able to possess women and make them
go insane Robert lebling explains quote
this can happen when a Lonely Woman
visits a public bath house and Strikes
up a conversation with another lonely
woman who happens to be a demon in
Disguise the ad then offers to wash the
woman's back suddenly the demon shows
its true nature and the unfortunate
woman falls
unconscious when she awakens she has
lost her
mind in some areas where farsy the
Iranian language is spoken such women
are called Jin Zada offspring of the
Jin According to Islamic tradition there
are various reasons why a possession can
happen as we've explained in earlier
videos there are different occult and
magical practices that have been popular
in the Islamic World across history such
as those involving talismans or
invocations and in the more malicious
examples
curses While most of the quote unquote
magic in this tradition is working with
God and the power of God there are some
examples of summoning or working with
Jin in different ways we saw this in the
famous or maybe I should say Infamous
sham mif for instance
and a gin possession can happen as a
result of this perhaps someone has
cursed you or one of your own rituals
involving Jin has backfired and now
you're in trouble in the case of theam
it is said that only owning a copy of
the book or reading it will bring Jin
upon you but Jin have emotions and
feelings too and a possession can also
be the result of you insulting or
harming them in some way as a kind of
retaliation in one of the core stories
from the thousand one kns the story of
the merchant and the Jin it tells of how
a merchant is confronted by an angry
ifet who wants to kill him the reason
the merchant was walking along eating
dates and throwing the seeds around
accidentally hitting and killing the son
of this particular ifet now in this
story this doesn't result in an actual
possession but it does showcase how Jin
can become angry with the behavior of
humans and might use possession as a
kind of retali ition or
Revenge Jin can also feel lust towards
human beings and there are instances of
sexual relations between humans and Jin
as well as cases where humans even marry
Jin indeed the famous early Muslim
philosopher and scientist alah wrote
that quote some Islamic theologians
allege that intermarriage and
crossbreeding has occurred between the
Jin and humans according to the almighty
statement make them Partners in wealth
and offspring this is apparent since
female gin undertake to seduce human men
out of passion seeking fornication and
likewise the men of the Gin human women
so say a possession actually happens how
does this manifest itself in other words
what are the symptoms of a genin
possession as you can imagine the
symptoms are there are a lot of symptoms
there lot different symptoms and many of
them today would simply be attributed to
mental disorders of different kinds
some common symptoms are mood shifts and
changes in personality depression
uncontrollable laughter or crying
epileptic convulsions a changed voice
like in those demon movies U suddenly
being able to speak a foreign language
that you didn't know before um recurring
nightmares and insomnia among much else
now some of you might be thinking many
of these kind of sound like me so am I
possessed by a Jin probably not as
symptoms will also often include
religious aspect such as um negative
reactions to the recitation of the Quran
or the call to prayer or a general
abandonment of religious observances
regardless it sounds like being
possessed by a Genny is pretty
unpleasant and it is certainly something
that people want to get rid of for this
reason there have existed different
techniques of exorcism or Ria in Arabic
that are employed to deal with such a
situation now this is truly a vast topic
and much what we have discussed in
earlier videos on the Islamic at ult
Sciences are directly related to it we
can see across history and in many
places still today that various kinds of
talismans and amulets are used to get
rid of gin and other troubles a Talisman
can technically be any object you're
probably thinking about some necklace
with a locker and that could definitely
be a Talisman but there are many other
things that could be employed in this
kind of magic too from a simple piece of
paper to bronze Bowl and even clothes
the important part was imbuing these
objects with occult power usually by
adding certain symbols writings or
images onto them some of the most common
ways of turning an object into a
Talisman would be to write on it the
names of God in Arabic primary of these
is of course the name Allah but one also
finds names like the merciful and Al
which means the one Etc if not God
himself then one might write the names
of one or more of his angels such as
jabel mik or one of his prophets perhaps
Muhammad Moses or Solomon for many
Shiites one might also write the names
of one of the imams or spiritual
successors to the prophet Muhammad very
common is also to write the shahada or
Muslim proclamation of
Faith there is no God but God or direct
verses from the Quran many verses like
the aat or Throne verse are thought to
be a especially powerful in this regard
so a person that is possessed by a jinny
could advise a specialist in these kinds
of Sciences and might be given an amulet
containing verses from the Quran that he
or she can wear around their neck maybe
hang them over their bed as another
example or other places in their home
Etc it is thought that the very presence
of these verses or names of God for
instance have such power in themselves
to ward off evil spirits if you have
visited a middle eastern home you'll
know that different kinds of amulets are
very common to find such as the hand of
Fatima for example which often has this
very exact
purpose there are also many other
different kinds of protective amulets
such as talismanic shirts and clothes
among much else and other images or
motifs that have protective Powers such
as the so-called magic squares in some
of the classic books of a cult Sciences
in the Islamic World such as the Sham
and
the we find different kinds of
instructions for
protection aside from wearing amulets or
protective verses words or images one
can also for instance burn the object on
which these words are written and then
inhale the
fumes so these are some of the more
occult practices for protection against
gin possession and one should remember
that these practices have been very
widespread and popular in the Islamic
kit world and still is in many parts of
of the Middle East today but they have
also been cre criticized and seen as un
Islamic by many scholars especially
today and indeed has even been seen as
the very opposite of Islamic as being
basically
heretical um and to these more um
skeptical or critical Scholars there is
only one particular form of Ria or or
exorcism that is legitimate according to
the religion which does not involve
these more ult aspects like talismans
for instance among these more quotequote
sa practices are such things as simply
reciting the Quran Over The Afflicted
person particularly certain suras or
verses that are thought to be effective
for this purpose such as the
aforementioned or The Haunting and
short or chapter of the Daybreak quote
say I seek refuge in The Lord of
Daybreak from the evil of what he has
created from the evil of darkness when
it enshrouds from the evil of those who
blow upon knots
and from the evil of the envier when he
envies according to the Exorcist
tradition in Islam written by Bal
Phillips this initial step is usually
followed by and here I quote quranic
verses may be recited over water and
given to the patient to drink olive oil
over which the Quran has been read may
be robbed on the aching
limbs three once communication is
established with the possessing Spirit
information is sought concerning its
name and its reason for possessing the
patient four through admonition scolding
and or persuasion the Jin or group of
Jin are then encouraged to
leave five if the possessing jinny
refuses to leave through encouragement
it is then tortured by further quranic
recitation it is commanded to leave and
to take an oath not to
return six beating may be resorted to in
order to inflict pain on the possessing
entity only when the human personality
is not conscious this is used in
conjunction with commands to the jny to
leave seven water over which the Quran
has been recited is used for drinking
and olive oil over which the Quran has
been recited is used for rubbing on the
aching parts of the body these are in
other words some of the most common and
recurring techniques for dealing with
gin possession but there are other more
unusual examples too there is for
instance the fasting tradition of Zar
that we find in places like Egypt
Ethiopia and across the Middle East
where Spirit possession is handled
through intense music and dance to
appease the possessing Spirits this is a
fascinating ritual complex that we will
dedicate a full episode to hopefully
later this month for this reason we
won't be going any deeper into it right
now but is worth knowing that such more
unique and elaborate forms of possession
and exorcism or in this case appeasement
exist as well so this has been only a
brief overview of the world of Jin
possession in the Islamic world we've
discussed that the very reality of this
kind of possession has been debated by
Islamic scholars throughout history but
that examples of it and and different
ways of of dealing with it uh can be
found both across history and today in
different regions of this larger Islamic
world in the Middle East we've also
explored a few different ways that
exorcism or Ria is used on people that
are afflicted with this kind of
possession hopefully this has been
educational as well as put you in nice
spooky October mood I will continue to
speak about the darker aspects of the
world's different religions and cultures
for the remainder of the month of
October and I hope you are as excited as
I am for the continuing of this year's
spooky season or shocktober as we call
it over here on the channel again look
forward to more spooky content over the
coming weeks and I will see you
then